good evening everybody and welcome to
this slightly delayed overview in
scrutiny committee rating on thursday
12th of august 2021 apologies we've had
some technical issues
my name is councillor vanessa bell and
i'm the chairman of this committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
issues to run through
members to set up for the meeting has
been designed to mitigate the covid
therefore can i ask all present to work
to the protocols agreed at council on
29th of april 2021 in the interest of
member and officer safety
we're streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you are giving your
consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hands up to indicate if
you wish to speak i will then invite you
at the appropriate time
when invited to speak please remove your
mask put on your visor i don't think we
do we need to put some visors i'm not
entirely sure i think
do what you feel comfortable with
members
as long as you're following the
protocols please reference a page of
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible and ensure
your microphones remain off when not
speaking
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
that i've already fallen up tonight and
advised that the fire exit is the door
behind the top table
that brings us on to item two apologies
for absence sir please and i have
apologies thank you chairman apologies
been received from council dueck and
councillor helm thank you
thank you
item three minutes it is recommended
that the minutes of the meeting held on
the 15th of april 2021 found on pages
five to eight are approved as a true and
accurate record
why so move do i have a second death
thank you councillor maize
does anybody wish to raise any matters
of accuracy or are we happy with those
i'll take that as that we're happy are
we happy to agree by scent
super thank you very much
item 4 declarations of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disposable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests or non-pecuniary
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to
paragraphs 6 to eight inclusive of the
code of conduct for members
do i have any members
counselor mr stan
thank you chair i'm not a member of this
committee but i have requests if i would
like to speak or ask the questions
depending on how the debate goes so i'd
just like to declare that i'm a asics
county councillor which i don't think
is
involves anything on tonight's agenda
and i'm also the leader of this council
thank you very much okay
members are reminded that they're also
required to disclose any interests any
such interests as soon as they become
aware should the need arise throughout
the meeting
item five public participation i can
advise that we have not received any
submissions from members of the public
at least if we have i've not
been told to take that as a knockout
okay that brings us on to agenda item 6
which is the full report of the
transformation board
so this can be found on pages 9 to 26
and i will turn to ms fuse to present
the item thank you
good evening members
following on from the 15th of april
where the committee considered an
interim report on the matter of
transformation learning from what we've
done the full report is now presented to
committee for consideration
the two questions that were agreed to be
addressed when the item was originally
added to the committee work plan in
january 2021
where did we achieve the outcomes of
transformation both at a high level and
the finer detail
which is presented throughout the report
and
for resident and customer experience and
council reputation what is the effect of
transformation
this question specifically is
highlighted in section 4 of appendix a
where there is a section of the table
that has customer and cost implications
in the april committee where the draft
report was presented members also asked
for further detail on the governance and
reporting of risks surrounding the
program
that's been included in the background
of section a at
the background section of appendix a
which is found on page 11 of your full
agenda pack
and examples shown in pages 23 to 25.
page 19 also shows the initial
implications that were signed off by
members when full council agreed the
blueprint document in 2018 which was
also requested
the interim report still required
financial detail of the programme which
would have included projected and actual
finances
this is now set out in pages 20 to 22 of
your gender pack
factoring in these additional areas of
information as well as the summary table
in pages 13 to 19 which analyzes the
original work packages the agreed
outcomes and an analysis to what which
extent they were achieved we've been
able to identify areas of learning from
the transformation program
which is in section two of the appendix
the key highlights from this are
uh that transformation work is an
ongoing and iterative process and
although there were large or
organizational changes between when the
blueprint was signed off in 2018
and when the structure went live in 2019
october
works is still ongoing with some of the
work packages in areas like ict and
process improvement
that when the revised structure went
live in october 2019
because not all of the work packages
were complete we couldn't fully underpin
the new structure
the impact of
so few staff being job matched and the
higher than expected turnover had an
immediate impact on project delivery and
an impact on staff well-being which has
been reflected in staff feedback
and a delay in the phone's
implementation had an impact on customer
experience at the time
due to the speed and the nature of the
process uh the training and the outcomes
were delivered by consultancy staff
which is also meant that
internal staff have taken time to build
knowledge and become custodians of what
was set out
financially there is also a staffing
variance of 12
to what was set out in the original
blueprint
this is made up of posts having to go
back in where the structure felt too
lean and additional resource
requirements of covid
there were also savings targets that
were identified as unachievable to the
tune of 337 000 pounds
and this has been factored in as part of
the medium-term financial strategy work
as a positive point of learning updates
to working practices in culture and
change to help put the organisation in a
good place to respond to challenges of
covid19
such as a shift to online working
some of these issues have already been
picked up and addressed operationally
for example resource gaps have been
addressed in the operational model and
staffing structures have been adjusted
accordingly
and a program of continual process
improvement work has been put in place
for the
organization the leadership team have
worked to address gaps and support staff
issues like well-being and in more
recent staff surveys we have seen
improvements in staff feedback
section 3 of the appendix on page 12 of
your full agenda pack
identifies areas where more work could
be done to build on transformation and
members are invited to reflect on both
the list provided and the information
set out in the report generally and
advise if they would
like to recommend any actions to council
or otherwise thank you
thank you very much
so um
members
i'm gonna go over to you for a debate
so has anyone got anything they would
like to say councillor mays
uh yeah thank you uh very much for the
for the presentation um with regard to
the high turnover of staff has that
actually slowed since transformation has
pretty much
come to a conclusion i know there are
areas that are still being worked on but
has this turnover of staff slowed um and
if so uh do you believe that that will
stay as such and therefore the culture
is is good um and um
all is well within the council as a
whole
thank you thank you
so um staff turnover and retention of
staff was added to the corporate risk
register and reported through
performance governance and audit and
that has reduced in risk rating on the
corporate risk register um i think it
was the last performance governance and
audit committee that that went through
but um yeah the the scoring has come
down so we see it as less of a corporate
risk than what we did
thank you could i come back mr
by all means thanks even though you
called me mistake i apologize for that
um
adam chen
um
now i forgot what's gonna ask
i'll come back thank you
i'm sorry
any other members
if not then i will invite councillor
stamp to speak but
no cancer stamp likes to let the members
go before her and certainly committee
members
have you remembered councillor mays
amaze
no i haven't but i was going to just
come back on the unachievable 300 000
that's no small amount of saving
um
why do we think that that was
unachievable why was it even included
in the transformation in the first place
um and at what point was that actually
identified as being unachievable
thank you
excellent question
so the identification happened as part
of the medium-term financial strategy
when they were reviewing the budgets
and but there was an overall pot so the
further savings actually amounted to an
estimated uh
we expected to save 891 000
and that was made up of things like
commercial income
um
strategic reductions in some of the you
know stopping some of the things that we
were doing um so and also
corporate budgets
um but percentage-wise compared to this
staffing um obviously that was a much
smaller percent of the savings and the
337 000 is what's been identified as
unachievable and which is a mix of those
commercial pots and those um assumed
strategic savings
if i'll allow you to come back then i'm
going to cancel the best yeah
um all i was going to ask was how will
that affect do you think um the
financial budgeting for 2122 and 22-23
thank you
i believe finance i'm not a finance
expert but i believe finance have
accounted for it already so i think
that's uh that that has already come par
forward as part of the medium-term
financial strategy reporting
thank you thank you council messenger
so the the modelling and the assumptions
were put together by ignite the
consultants
and obviously the assumption was the one
million um but the savings that have
been able to been achieved is 882 940 so
the variance is 12
on what was modeled
thank you although i
we're all very aware that we are going
to have to put in
put stuff back in some places because
as mentioned we have become too lean in
some areas and
there will be more yes
although i'm not sure that those
expertise um sat within the organization
at the times to be able to do that
modelling exercise
yeah i mean i i go to you in a second
cancer skills but after i've put my oar
in which is that you know personally i
don't think it was successful but you
know that's that's my view and later on
i'll come on to
the things that i think are important
the most important things which are i
won't use the word customer because that
implies choice resident satisfaction and
staff satisfaction but we'll come to
that later on cancer schemes
uh yes it just occurs to me listening to
this that we're 12 12 out but i'm
assuming the uh ignite proposals were a
bit of a menu from which we chose what
we wanted so we cut what we wanted to
cut got as close to it as we could and
decided not to cut as much staff does
that make sense is that what happened
so the 12 variants is where we've had to
add um
post back in so uh the initial um
restructure happened
um and the set out of the structure
accounted for that one million but we've
had to add additional posts back into
the organization since then
so if i could come back that basically
means that their
their predictions for being able to run
attack with the council on
less stuff just proved to be impractical
but they weren't about 90 percent right
is ultimately 88 right okay thanks
thank you count for the passenger again
thank you anybody else wish to speak i
will go to council stamp then please
chairman thank you i think i should wait
until you say your bit because you're
the chairman of the committee and i know
you had um quite um valid views on the
transformation and i don't think it
would be fair for me to actually step in
before you've said yours i have got some
points to make but i'm sure you may
cover them and i'm not one to steal
anybody's thunder so thank you i'll wait
thank you very much cancer stamp um i
mean my concerns yes because this is
looking um
we're just talking about savings i mean
my concerns are
services to our residents which
i believe have suffered
enormously through transformation
not least through the digital
digitalization
of the council i believe we're still not
open for face-to-face
people to come in
and
you know the lack of consideration for
the fact that
we do have quite an aging population but
more more importantly there are large
swathes of the district where you cannot
get internet
so
there are large large numbers of
residents who simply cannot access
council services
because they have been
digitized
and um my second point was around staff
satisfaction we've touched briefly on
recruitment and retention
i was horrified
to see that even with a 19
increase the level of staff satisfaction
is still so low
not so concerned i've looked into
resident satisfaction with councils and
i'm generally speaking across the
country
satisfaction levels aren't enormously
high
but certainly with um
start in terms of staff
satisfaction
i mean i i will mention perhaps now the
recommendations that i intend to make
and
we can perhaps discuss those so
i'll be looking at staff satisfaction
surveys being carried out half yearly
with a target of 90
to improve retention and um
appointments
status resident satisfaction surveys
carried out annually with a target of 75
positive
an overhaul and revamp of the website
making navigation easier for members of
the public and also
looking at the use of language and plain
english
it's really difficult to navigate and
there's lots of good information really
good information
about
the final item on this agenda that you
can't necessarily find because the
navigation is
challenging shall we say
i think we still need to identify areas
of organisational deficiency including
where there are already staff shortages
we really need to promote a balanced
resident journey incorporating digital
and face-to-face experiences
and
lastly overall really enjoy the ensure
that this agile working is always
focused on customer name balanced with
health and well-being of staff
and
taking away the focus from saving saving
savings we are here to provide a service
to our residents
and that is our primary function
so i will now hand over to
you cancer stand
yeah thank you um thank you for the
presentation uh miss hughes
um i have um some actual concerns i'd
like to actually congratulate the team
members the co2 actually delivered had
to deliver this initially many of us who
are elected now weren't around when the
decision was taken to implement the
transformation we understand why
it was felt it was necessary but i
really do question the actual
effectiveness and
now madam chair and members um i think
we're all actually seeing where the gaps
are
rising
um we have we only have to look at some
issues that are going on in the council
last year we know was totally unfounded
because we had a pandemic
we know that staff had to even though
they were going through the biggest
transformation many lost their jobs many
lost their livelihoods i mean i was
absolutely astounded madam chair about
the cost of the redundancy figures i
would love to know how many staff we had
and how many we have ended up with
uh and i would have liked to send the
the the model the matrix that decided on
how we could deliver the services we
were expected to deliver not only by law
but our expectation from our residents
our customers whichever way around you
want to say that we refer to our the
public we're actually here to serve
um
i'm not going to knock anything that was
done previously what i want to do though
is look forward and i think we have to
be realistic
we have not we we haven't saved the
money i feel madam chair and you i'm
quite you know quite willing to be
corrected if i'm wrong we haven't made
the savings that we were told we would
make i'd love to know actually the true
cost of how much it cost us
in our own office of time as well as
ignite when they came in the package
must have been presented you are going
to save this amount of money and i would
have really hoped i don't know if they
did there was some come back if we
failed
because this was a model that was agreed
and approved at this council that they
accepted now surely if you and agree a
contract or a model there is some clause
behind that that says if you have failed
these are the these are the things that
you will have to do whether you can give
us a hundred or two hundred thousand
back because
i am seeing uh madam chair and members
the repercussions of this now and i
think it is having an effect on all our
staff who's had to work through the
pandemic they're all having to job share
they had to be trained in their new jobs
if you listen to the presentation which
was excellent by misuse it was referred
to the contractors who actually did the
work and then our teams had to be
retrained in their roles that all takes
time and has a massive effect on
people's mental health now i'm the great
believer in supporting staff and i think
many members in here know i a champion
and hopefully look after our staff in
this um in our council because they are
the backbone of what makes us the
standard we are
i don't want to be negative madam chair
but i have seen the recommendations that
are going to come from the chair um but
i do have concerns that i don't i think
it was needed certain areas ict et
cetera we've done well because we we
managed to go through the pandemic and
if we hadn't upgraded there's no way we
could have been on course and ahead of
the many other councils in that respect
but as i've said for the third time now
it is now showing that we've got gaps
and we are going to have to come back to
this council on our taxpayers to ask for
more money
from a mid financial um term and next
year because we cannot provide the
services now i don't know what other
members feel but i particularly don't
want to cut services but sometimes you
have to make a choice and we're going to
have to make a choice as a council
if we don't agree to these um
either a restructure or or agreeing with
some more staff madam chair
and i think i better stop because i feel
quite passionate about this because we
all want this council to do well and we
want to provide a first-class service
and i'm afraid i can't i don't see how
we can do that at the moment with what
with what we've got madam chair
no questions it's more of a statement i
don't want to say anything because i
think miss hughes and the team have
worked very hard behind the scenes to
produce an excellent very informative
report but one question so i'm actually
going back on myself i'm interested in
the number of staff i'm really
interested in the number of staff we had
running the same services before
transformation and what we've got now
um if that you don't come now that if
that could be given to all members madam
chair if that's all right with you that
would be useful thank you thank you for
allowing me to speak madam chair
you're welcome cancer staff and thank
you for your very valid points would
that be feasible yeah i don't have those
figures to hand now but we can certainly
just wait yeah to be circulated thank
you and cancer staff i share your
concerns i really do i i question
whether at this point in time the
council is some
fit for purpose with uh i know that's a
big statement but in some areas
in some areas i hasten to add there are
things we're doing exceptionally well
i'll come to you in a second councilman
there are things we're doing
exceptionally well and i'm quite excited
actually about
you know the last item on the agenda
today because i don't want to give
anything away but there are areas in
which we're we're not doing as well as
we should be so yes cancer stanton
councillor maize and councillor thank
you i'd just like to come back and the
areas that we are doing really well like
we are doing really well and the staff
have have worked extremely extremely
hard um but like i said
we are fit for purpose madam chair
we provide excellent services to be over
dramatic
we provide and i do think a customer
service and lots of our our officers um
work extremely hard and they do reply
the majority of the time do reply as
soon as possible madam chair and i've
also done a carly mays council amazed
because i've forgotten the point i was
going to make so i reserved the right to
my statement was absolutely no slur on
our officers who are absolutely
fantastic and i cannot thank officers
enough for the support
certainly that i've received and the
work that they've put in it's the
structure
that in some places is problematic so i
must clarify that that absolutely no
criticism of our offices
whatsoever councillor mays then
councillor passenger
yeah thank you um madam chair um i just
wanted to say that
your staff are the most important asset
in a business
whatever that is and i do feel very
strongly that ignite failed to recognize
this during their transformation
and we are now left with the
consequences thank you thank you i agree
i think staff were treated as
commodities really and i i would
absolutely agree with that so
thank you
council messenger
thank you i mean just as a silly thing
really i mean would it not be possible
to do a sort of reverse modeling so as
where unite i've done a modeling
projecting how much we could save and
whatever whatever but reverse modeling
maybe going back historically to as
councillor stamp said how many staff we
had
to provide the services that we're still
trying to provide with less staff and
how much it would cost to put all those
people back so a sort of reversed
thought pattern so for this council now
as we think maybe it needs more staff
which i think it does
um exactly we could work out how much of
a budget we would need to do that
perhaps that sort of modelling might be
interesting
big pace of work
off the top of my head thank you
i don't know miss hughes whether that'd
be feasible
yeah i suppose the answer is that the
variance between um staffing figures is
that 882 000 um you know to go back
right back to when um but i think if i
get the figure over around ftes um
before transformation and fts now that
will give you a better idea
thank you i may come back i mean i think
also i think communicating this to the
public because i think one one of the
main problems we face is when we ask for
a little more budget from people they
think we're just sort of you know i
don't know
getting rid of it but i think if we can
explain or get it out to them that to
actually provide the service that we
used to have
it will cost
this much money it's more of a realistic
it's something people i think can get
hold of better when you realize exactly
where your money's going rather than
sort of to odd schemes and
whatever but when they they know it's
about their services i think
we have a better chance of actually then
going going out there to the residence
once again and saying look we need
another
whatever just just to get everything
back to the way it was
thank you cancer schemes then cancer
it's always a problem isn't it
presenting
things like the wage bill the massive
wage bill uh to the public because the
public go well you don't need all those
people and it's just a gravy train and
they come up with these phrases because
they don't understand how hard it is to
run a council on all the difficulties it
seems to me that transformation has done
it what it can to save a million pounds
but i think the problem was it started
from a point where we were pretty cut to
the bone anyway
but on the other hand the council has
financial problems he's got to do
something so we're going to so
but
of course massive pressure has come upon
officers
being asked frankly to do too much
uh and my heart goes out to them and
let's hope we can find a clever solution
that
alleviates that pressure while still
maintaining the best possible services
thank you council
yeah thank you madam chair i think um
we've got to be realistic we we have um
it has gone this far but we have got to
actually look at going forward and to
make some changes i mean if you actually
look into the transformation there's
only one part um that i was constantly
concerned about was some of it was
the what i call the um balancing was
commercial yeah we were supposed to be
looking at um commercial projects how we
could bring an income in but because i i
personally don't feel that the
transformation actually
allocated enough staff or an area that
that could actually make some inroads
into providing an income for the council
it was too thin i think there was one
commercial manager
and the commercial manager has been
totally run off their feet because of
having to do things within covid and i'm
not just singling that manager out i
know many managers has had to multitask
and go to support other members because
we have just been too thin thin on the
ground
but saying that we are where we are i
can't remember who says that but i know
it's a well-known saying we are where we
are we've got to look forward and
hopefully the council will be able to
bring
something forward
soon to actually make some
recommendations to adjust the structure
as and when um that we feel we can but
what i would like to do also madam chair
is to thank the
people behind the scenes like you know
tara you know the committee services
those sorts of people who actually
appear day in day out the i.t people
like that that don't always got to go to
mention um for actually keeping us
running on the rail tracks
and also the directors we all know we
get a lot of bad publicity and get
accused of all sorts of things left
right and center
but i do feel that um what they have
done extremely well for the trans
transformation that was after all put on
them by members it was a member decision
not an officer decision absolutely um
thank you madam chair thank you very
much and yeah absolutely without
committee services i and i t i would
appear as even more of a buffoon than i
already do so thank you guys for your
support councillor maze
thank you madam chair um you put forward
some recommendations i would like to
actually uh propose that we
adopt those recommendations going
forward um in some form i don't know how
you would want to actually record those
um
but i would like to second that or
propose whichever way around we did that
so so i will propose those
recommendations that's the second from
councilman mays
so i then propose that we
that we close off the item with those
recommendations now i'll go over the
recommendations again
they were
to carry out staff satisfaction surveys
half yearly with a target of 90
satisfaction
resident satisfactions annually with a
target of 75 satisfaction
using a variety of methods
overhaul and revamp of website i believe
this works already going on so i don't
think we're
putting any extra work on offices which
i'm very loved to do
including relevance of information
provided identify areas of
organizational deficiency including
where there are already staff shortages
promote a balanced customer journey
incorporating digital and face-to-face
experience
and ensure that agile working is always
focused on customer needs balanced with
health and well-being staff
members are we happy to agree that by a
sense or do we cancel the stamp um sorry
sorry we would i was just nuttering
while you were speaking so apologies for
that i just wondered why and if somebody
could tell me why that this resident
satisfaction surveys target 75
um i personally think the residents we
should be working as
to the highest as what we possibly can
but i've been assured there are reasons
behind that and if somebody would like
to i'm sure miss hughes can actually
fill not just me but the residents
because it does look as though we're
short changing them so an explanation
would be fantastic
i'm unwilling to
dump this on miss hughes although i'm
happy to but i've had a look at surveys
across the board um resident
satisfaction in local local
authorities across the country and it is
generally low and i think that's to i
will hand over to you in a minute but my
personal view is that is to do with who
we are and what we do
and it will be things like my bins don't
collected that don't get collected there
aren't enough dog poop bits that
it is we are always as councils
going to be the bad guy in some areas i
don't know sure if you can help out
further with that yeah i've been
involved in resident surveys for many
years and i think 60
is usually of a good number in terms of
resident satisfaction um but what we
could do with that particular
recommendation rather than actually have
a number is have
um that resident satisfaction is higher
than average in essex and then benchmark
ourselves against other organizations as
well
and look into
you know if you
sort of want to aim
i'm happy to make that amend cancer
stand yes
thank you
um yes i take on board what you've said
but would they be the detail behind it
so for example councillor bell the
chairman's just turned around and said
that it's the bin collection we know
recently my inbox has been full about
bing collections because of what's been
going on recently which is unfortunate
but obviously people are going down sick
with covid it's the fact of life whether
people like it or not people are still
getting covered and people are very
poorly with it um so would that
information be readily available say for
example we are at 60 complaints instead
of the 75 or whatever that it says well
you've got 80 or 90 complaints about
bing collection but we've got i don't
know uh 75 percent who actually
compliment us on something else so we've
got a balance
a breakdown yes please to drill down and
give the information at the back
yep so the resident survey that we run
has about 40 questions in it so um what
we do is we drill down analysis so of
the people that were satisfied with our
services we asked them what they were
satisfied about so we do have and we
create a full 30-page report when we do
the analysis of the resident survey
yes 40 questions um
what's the sort what sort of response
rate do we get how many people fill in
40 questions
uh the last one was 303 responses that
we got
out of how many
taxpayers
yeah so out of all of the households in
malden but that's actually quite
there's actually quite a good number um
so when i worked at colchester during
residence surveys we might get a
thousand returned but that was when we
sent out postal surveys with a free post
envelope it's quite hard to get
residents to engage with
president surveys
historically through the chair if i may
come back
one reason why it might be hard is 40
questions
now of course i know you want lots of
detail but you're getting lots of detail
from less people people who are more
committed maybe there's a case for the
upcoming working group to have a look at
or
have a look at how we can make those
surveys
um just a little bit more likely to be
answered that just as a thought thank
you cancer schools i mean i've always
been taught that 30 percent is
the lowest statistically relevant number
so but we're not under failed miserably
on that yeah what is the percentage if
you don't mind through the chair it was
about north point nor north something
isn't it yes so that's
moving on so um members are we happy to
close this item with the
recommendations and can we agree that by
sent members
agreed thank you very much and thank you
again to officers particularly
cheryl for the enormous amount of work
that has been put into this so many many
thanks to that
okay moving on swiftly to
item seven
which is the working group of overview
and scrutiny now um
just for the benefit of
our new member
we have the working group the work the
role of the working group is to
act as a filter to triage items that are
put forward to to the overview and
scrutiny committee so the forms will
come in from members
and the working group will meet and
discuss those
and then a decision will be made i mean
it might just be that they're actually a
request for information rather than a
scrutiny item in which case
they the information requested can be
provided
it might be decided that it's not
appropriate for scrutiny or the item
might then be agreed to go forward to
the scrutiny committee so that's the
role of the working group
now
the working group does not
have to be
politically balanced but i like it to be
politically balanced if possible because
i think it's
fair
um so
from there can i point
i can nominate myself for after me
um counselor
it may affect people wanting to work on
the group but is it possible that uh
working group meetings could be virtual
since they're not uh public no because
decisions are made i believe and that
i've been am i right in thinking that
decision making meetings have to be in
person i think they can
so from the chair
i would like to nominate myself
councillor mays
counsellor and bill
and
counselor no
counselor hublot would you like to have
a cracklet
excellent and
councillor jewick but he's not here so
i don't really know where we stand
cancer schemes were you um
proposing an interest there
um yes
if you want to nominate me i i'll i'll
i'll attend if it's virtual do my
favorites
you'll second all of them
can we agree that by a cent then um
yes i am because i don't feel it's fair
to nominate someone in their accents
tara so
i mean i would like well
it'll be in the minutes that we we are
tempted to be politically balanced but
with uh neither of the non-aligned
members here it's been slightly
difficult to do so
super we have a working group many
thanks everyone
i do apologize for my absolute ignorance
in terms of how that works
so moving on to appointment of
representatives on liaison committees
this can be found on pages 31-13
so to remind members of the
existing representatives on liaison
committees and for new appointments to
be made for the municipal year to may
2022
so um
yes pages 31-32 so um
i would like from the chair to nominate
councillor maize to the health overview
policy and scrutiny committee for the
municipal uh year
useful year municipal year to may 2022
to have a secondary
council of assinger and cancer cuba
thank you very much
yes i did want to speak um thank you
chair thank you cancer skins can we just
thank the um
councillor who has actually now not
going to be on there anymore
he's he's done a lot for this council
and i think it should be acknowledged
and recognized all the years of hard
services put put on this council thank
you chad yes councillor brian bill thank
you very much i'm not sure you actually
had to do anything very much on that
committee
[Laughter]
chairman you didn't have to say that you
could have just taken it
just so you didn't attend any meetings
by yes absolutely uh councillor bill is
i'd rather think how many meetings
councillor bill has attended over his 32
years of
service
brilliant so that was agreed i believe
whizzing on through
which brings us on to
item number nine debt recovery work plan
this can be found on pages 27-28
and i move to
mrs green who has a presentation
for us
so over to you screen
thank you chairman and good evening
members um
we i have a presentation for you this
evening which i hope will
address some of the areas that have been
identified in the previous scrutiny item
as members will know this original piece
of scrutiny was agreed back in january
and he had an updated report in april
but there were clearly still a number of
areas
that our members felt weren't covered
so what i'm going to do tonight members
is actually to do a presentation to you
which will take you through the whole
debt recovery process
which i hope will not only um help with
a wider understanding of the process but
will give you the reassurance about our
internal processes
and we'll also back this up with some
data which i hope you will find useful
thank you
so the whole debt recovery process
is actually laid down in legislation so
it's not something that as a local
authority we have very much discretion
over
um
but we we do have a discretion as to how
we act within that legislation and what
are we doing today is to talk around
what we do over and above what the
legislation requires us to do
so to start with i'd just like to go
over the the initial process so
as members will know every resident will
receive a bill every year um
it's also known as a demand notice
that's what the legislation calls it um
but it is
for all purposes it's what everybody
refers to as a bill
everybody's entitled to at least one
reminder if they default on their
payments
and they will also receive a final
notice
if the payment isn't made then that can
result in a summons being issued and
then if the payment isn't made then it
will proceed to court to request a
liability order
once we get that liability order that
gives the authority some very
wide-ranging powers
all of these powers are given to us as
part of the liability order so we don't
have to go back to court to
use any of these they are all within our
own gift
and that's really important because
we need to have very good processes in
place to ensure that those powers that
were given by the court are used
proportionately and reasonably and
fairly
so the first
piece of um authority we have is we can
request information about a debtor's
income
now
the debtor is actually obliged legally
to provide that information to us
that often doesn't happen but the law
requires that they are required to give
that to us
we have the power to give an attachment
of earnings orders so we can serve a
notice on an employer to request that
the money is taken out of that person's
wages
if they're receiving benefits we can
request the department of work and
pensions to take money out of that
person's benefit
for members if you are receiving members
allowance we have the right to take
money out of your members allowance
we can send in what is previously called
a bailiff it's now an enforcement agent
to actually remove goods to the value of
the debt
we can place a charging order on a
property so that gives us a legal
interest in that property
we can also instigate bankruptcy and
winding up procedures
and ultimately we can request the court
to commit that person to prison
so that's why you know we are custodians
of a lot of responsibility and we do we
do take that very very seriously
so that's just giving you the background
of the legislation
thanks tara
so the
the way in which we ensure that we are
having a very careful regard to how we
use those powers
um is we have a corporate debt strategy
and that doesn't cover just council tax
that covers business rates and other
debts that are owed to the council
the basis of that strategy is very much
a focus on early intervention what we do
know is if we can
start to work with the resident the
customer very early on
then we're able to avoid a lot of
problems so that's very much the focus
of the strategy and very much the focus
of what our day-to-day work is
we will always make arrangements rather
than take enforcement action so we make
many many arrangements sometimes
multiple arrangements with customers
because that's what we want to do we
don't want to take enforcement action so
that's very much the focus
through every contact with customers
we'll be looking to identify if we have
any vulnerable customers
and that's set out in the in the cadet
strategy identifying the sort of things
that the staff need to look out for
when we're dealing with them
and flagging up whether or not we need
to take additional steps with those
customers
right the way through the process will
always support our customers
so it's it's very much a
looking to see what we can do to help
the customers
and we and we have a very holistic
approach um the council to if somebody
has got a council tax debt they've
probably got other debts as well
probably rent perhaps fuel bills
so we aren't looking at it from the
single point of view of that person
knows as council tax and that's all
we're concerned with it's very much very
holistic approach
and we put in place additional controls
for the most severe forms of enforcement
action so things like a bailiff or
winding up charging orders they're all
things that require to be sanctioned by
a manager and there would need to be a
business case put forward for the most
extreme forms of action
no officer would be able to
for example start a winding up procedure
or bankruptcy or a charging order
without going through a very detailed
process and really being able to justify
that action
thanks tara
and the additional support that we give
residents as i've already mentioned the
big focus for us is very much making
those arrangements at the earliest
possible opportunity
identifying if somebody is vulnerable
and giving them advice and support
and that is much wider than just about
paying their council tax debt so the
sort of things that we would be doing is
identifying other debts that they have
and making sure that we're referring
them to those support agencies we work
very very closely with the citizens
advice service
and we do a lot of referrals to them
and we work very very proactively with
those services so it isn't the case if
we hand them over to somebody
we will work for example if the citizens
device are working with the customer we
would work with the citizens device and
the customer together very much a
partnership approach
we actually do fund that independent
device service so it's really important
that the customer can access independent
advice whilst we work in partnership
with citizens advice
customers have the right to speak to the
citizens of ice and to deal
confidentially with them they may not
want to share all of the details of
their debts with us but that's why we
have that independent advice service
one of the things that we will very
often do is where we do identify
somebody that has
um significant
and certainly for vulnerable customers
the very first thing we would do is you
suspend any action
so if we were for example we had got an
enforcement agent involved we identified
that that person was potentially
vulnerable
we'd suspend recovery action and we
wouldn't even need to do that ourselves
because our enforcement agents know that
if they do identify anybody that's
vulnerable the first thing they do is
they will refer that person back to
their own vulnerable person support unit
and suspend action
one of the other things we can do is
review the cost sometimes we find out
fairly late down the line
that customer
hasn't engaged with us and it's got
right through the court process they've
had extra costs
and so we will always look at those and
decide whether or not it's proportionate
to actually charge those costs and we
can wave costs in appropriate
circumstances isn't something that we
would do as a matter of course but
certainly in exceptional situations we
would absolutely be looking at that
and we do have the ability to consider
some remit of the debt on the basis of
exceptional hardship
um again it's something that
has a direct cost to the local authority
we pick the bill up for that so we have
to be
careful in how we do that but we do have
a policy that covers exceptional
hardship and we do have
some funds that have been made available
through essex county council through the
preset process
to enable us to give that additional
help to those customers that are
suffering those exceptional hardship
situations
so as we mentioned vulnerable customers
that it's really important for us to
identify them at every stage so whether
they're talking to our customer services
team whether they're emailing writing to
us
we'll be looking for any triggers that
might help identify that person is
vulnerable
within the strategy it does set out very
clearly there isn't a single definition
and we have looked at
our definition of a vulnerable customer
or our guidelines now very much in line
with most other local authorities in
fact i think i probably go far to say
ours are probably more detailed than a
lot of other authorities
so that gives the staff a discretion for
themselves to identify if they consider
somebody's vulnerable
we can as we said we can suspend action
that's now actually embedded in
legislation called breathing space but
that's something that we have always
done so we haven't waited for the
legislation to come in we've always
given customers that opportunity to have
that exactly what it says a breathing
space to be able to try and sort their
situation out
the arrangements we make are appropriate
for the circumstances we need to
obviously collect the debt in a
reasonable period of time but equally we
have to be realistic about the customs
circumstances so we will always use the
discretion to make an appropriate
arrangement
particularly if we make an arrangement
that is longer than ideally we would
like to repay the debt
we would insist that the customer does
seek that additional support because if
they're not able to pay the debt back in
a reasonable time it means they have got
significant debt issues
and we would normally get the customers
agreement to refer them through to some
additional support through the citizens
advice you have some excellent dedicated
officers that deal with specialist
support for the people in debt so we
would always do that
as i said earlier we always look at not
just the debt that that customer owe to
us we actually have that holistic
approach and as i mentioned earlier we
do have the ability in exceptional
hardship cases to
review
um whether or not we are able to offer
some financial assistance through
waiving and all are part of the debt and
also through perhaps waiving some of the
court costs
thanks tara
so he mentions that we have an
independent advice service
so it isn't a service that the customers
have to come to the council for the same
people that they owe the debt for it's
independent and we procure that through
a procurement process and it's currently
being delivered by malden citizens
advice
it's really important the customer can
see it is independent it isn't somebody
who works for the council giving them
that advice
and as i mentioned earlier there's a lot
of support that they are able to give
and the sort of things are debt advice
budgeting advice so someone's in debt is
probably because they're not managing
their budget so it isn't
it's no good just solving the current
debt issue it really needs that budget
and support so they're able to provide
that
part of that will be looking at their
income so
can they maximize their income are they
getting all the benefits they're
entitled to
are they paying an excessively high
tariff for their fuel it's a whole range
of how can they maximize that person's
income for them to try and help them get
out of debt
they can also support people with
benefit appeals um probably one of the
the areas that's probably most in these
papers is things like the personal
independent payments um for people that
are disabled where they
suddenly find that they have a
a benefit that they have had for many
years it's withdrawn and the citizens
advice are absolute experts in terms of
providing support with appeals apologies
members because i should have the
figures with me but i believe it's
something like over 90 success rate with
the appeals they support customers with
very very high success rate so very very
good
and as i mentioned as well as providing
that very independent service
independent of us
we also work very very proactively with
them with the customers agreement and we
do have regular liaison meetings with
our debt recovery team with with the
citizens advice so we work very well
alongside them
so as i mentioned we have to be very
very careful with the powers that we've
given because they are quite extensive
powers
so they're not used by any member of
staff they're only used by experienced
and trained specialist staff
we only use enforcement powers where the
customer has not engaged with us or that
all other methods that we've tried to
engage with them have failed
and the most severe which
include the charging orders bankruptcy
the actual removal of goods and commits
all have to be approved by senior staff
it's not something any of our staff
would be able to do without a detailed
analysis for reasons being able to
justify it being approved by senior
manager
i think one of the areas of concern was
enforcement agent so again i think we
just want to cover a little bit more
detail on that
so we would only ever use an enforcement
agent where the customers fail to engage
with us or where we have absolutely
exhausted every other opportunity with
them
customers are always given an
opportunity to reach a payment
arrangement before the enforcement
agents are instructed
so
part of once we get the court order we
will write to the customer
and we'll give them that opportunity um
to engage with us so we would never ever
appoint an enforcement agent without
giving the customer an opportunity
and and as i go when we go through the
end i will go through the process with
you and you'll see just how many
opportunities customers are given to
make arrangements with us
it's about five or six before it would
even get to this stage
we will always give our authority before
we remove any goods from a customer
and as i'll mention at the very end
fortunately that happens extremely
rarely
most of the
most of the monies that are collected by
enforcement agencies are via having an
arrangement of payment arrangement with
customers
so we keep very sort of tight reins on
our enforcement agents
we have regular meetings with them and
we monitor them through a service level
agreement review meeting
and you know we do have that regular
liaison with them
and
the enforcement agents you can't just
have anybody going in and doing this
they are all their actions are regulated
that includes the time of the day that
they're allowed to attend premises etc
so it is very much and they can't go and
see what they want to do it's very
regulated
so the enforcement agents can make
payment arrangements
and that is absolutely
what our intention is is that we would
want our enforcement agents to actually
collect this as a payment arrangement
any vulnerable customers that they
identify are referred to a completely
separate team and the enforcement is
suspended
so as soon as they pick that up
we don't proceed until we've really the
enforcement agents have reviewed through
the separate team
completely independent of the actual
enforcement agents whether
that's appropriate to continue
and if the enforcement agents and their
team have any concerns they will always
come back to us to take instructions
if we refer the case to an enforcement
agent there are some additional costs
but those costs are very minimal as long
as the customer engages so the first
thing the enforcement agent will do is
they will write to the customer and say
we've been asked to collect this council
tax account from you
please contact us to make a payment
arrangement
um
the fees that are charged are set down
in legislation so again the bailiffs
can't decide enforcement agents can't
decide what they want to charge they are
set down
one of the things that we require is
that when the enforcement agents do
attend
they wear body-worn cameras
and
goods are only removed from premises as
an absolute last resort
we have had a few complaints previously
and we have been able to get that
footage back from the enforcement agents
from their cameras
and we have been able to very
satisfactorily go back and share with
the customer actually this is what
happened
because i think sometimes
people
it can be a very difficult situation
and sometimes what's said isn't perhaps
what somebody's heard
so that having those body-worn cameras
are really really useful useful for for
the customer's protection as well as the
enforcement agent
and the enforcement agents do have a
formal complaint process
and that's something that we get advised
about and that's something we would take
part in
so
for some authorities my my experience
has been that some authorities will say
sorry you need to complain to the
enforcement agent that's nothing to do
with us
we actually take the opposite view so
the enforcement agents have their own
complaint process but we will actively
be part of that so we will want to see
the report we will want to see
the investigation the evidence what has
been done to investigate this complaint
and we own that because at the end of
the day we've instructed that
enforcement agent to take that action so
it's very much
our responsibility
during the pandemic we have taken a
slightly different approach um
we
understand that customers have been a
very difficult position many have been
in a position where they have lost
livelihoods income
have had illness so it's been very it's
been very challenging for them so
during the period of the pandemic we've
taken a much more
proportionate approach so we have
not been as rigorous
in some of the action we've taken in
terms of sending out reminders
we've allowed people to have a lot more
time to repay debts
we've taken a lot less enforcement
action
and we have
been able to provide some additional
financial support through the cancer tax
support scheme that the government have
provided some additional funding for and
that's been very much targeted at those
that are on the lowest income so that
has been
very i think
helped an awful lot of people
so moving forward
whilst things are starting to come
because it's starting to become a little
bit more normal people are able to
return to work
what we're very conscious of is a lot of
the issues that customers
have had lots of income etcetera isn't
that's not going to go away overnight
the customers are and residents are
going to be having some of these
financial impacts and emotional impacts
for many years to come
so certainly during this year we're
continuing with that proportionate
approach and giving customers more time
to pay their debts
and we also introduce some some
additional contacts before we start any
any enforcement action so
whereas customers might have had five or
six contacts from us um
we will be increasing those so again
we're putting in those extra steps
and and we've also making sure that
there's more time before we take court
action normally we would have taken
court action
much earlier in the year again we're
just giving customers a bit more
breathing space a bit more time before
any court action is being taken this
year
so the next slide i hope members will
come see the detail on that side i will
talk you through it um and this is the
data and the stats behind some of the
things i've talked to you about
so the very first line is just to kind
of just confirm that we do sen we do
have between 27 to 28 000 properties the
data on here is based upon a range of
dates because what we didn't want to do
is to give you just a one year snapshot
because that actually doesn't give you
the reassurance that this is
something that is embedded within our
processor so what we've done is we've
looked at 2014 to 19 which is a good
representative period prior to when
covered hit
so during that time total properties
between 27 and 28 000 properties that we
were sending bills to
the council tax we collect is between um
from 2014 it was 35 million
42.2 million in 2019 so as you can see
it's huge amounts of money that we we
have to collect
our collection rate which i apologize
isn't on here during that time
was
i think fairly significant um we've got
most years was in excess of 98 so it's
between
98.1 to 98.3
and i think the best year was 93.6
um through 98 98.6 so we are collecting
more than 98 of our council tax every
year
which nationally is on the par with with
national collection rates
and across their six hours is actually
quite good as well
one of the things that we're very very
keen to do is to try to get our
residents to sign up to direct debit
because it's
so much easier for them to budget
and customers that are on direct debit
and having those regular payments are
far less likely to fall into a reason
and get into a position of getting into
enforcement action
so we've had quite a targeted approach
to that and really encouraged the take
up so
over those five years we've increased
the direct debit take up from 68
up to nearly 73
and that's something that we continue to
encourage customers to do
in the course of a year we issue
somewhere between fifty one thousand to
fifty two and a half thousand bills a
year
and then the next figures underneath it
are the percentage of those bills that
then go on to have reminders enforcement
action
and as you'll see it's a decrease in
figure so from the customers or
residents that are sent bills
um about 13 of those end up with getting
a reminder
at that point when they get the
reminders we do an awful lot of work to
get those people into payment
arrangements and avoid further action
if they don't make those arrangements or
they make them and they fall behind they
will get what's called a final notice um
which is the kind of prerequisite to
enforcement action
about somewhere in about four so between
about five percent of our um
of the bills we send out end up with the
final note just so you can see there's
quite a steep
um reduction in those that start off
with getting a reminder and then go
further
so of that five percent
roughly about three percent of those
then go on to receive a summons
when the customers receive a summons um
we do get quite a lot of payment at that
stage so when it goes to court we get
the liability orders
we're talking about two percent of our
original bill debts actually getting to
a summon stage
once we get the liability order
all those residents will get a letter
asking about details of their income and
expenditure
and asking them to engage with us to
make a payment arrangement and every
single resident will get as a minimum
one of those letters
if we
go into um taking some action so we're
going to go into an arrangement and that
arrangement fails
we would send out another information
request to find out about what their
revised circumstances are
so as a minimum the residents would
always get one of those opportunities
but
more frequently we would get probably
two or three of those
um once we've got the liability orders
for those people that don't enter into
entertainment arrangements with us
we've then got the um the attachment
orders so the attachment of earnings
orders
so um
between 0.2 and 0.4
of our our debts end up on attachment
orders
that's not always a such a bad thing
because some of our residents actually
quite like that actually coming out of
their pay and knowing that that's
deducted at source if they're struggling
but it is still a relatively small
number
um again people who are in receipt of
benefits we can do attachment a benefit
order so a small amount is taken out of
their benefits again quite often
customers like that because it helps
them budget
what we then come down to is when we
then get get to an enforcement agent
stage so if we've explored all the
opportunities to try and enter an
arrangement to do an attachment order
we then would then look at some form of
enforcement action and sending those
cases to an enforcement agent
apologies members there's one that i've
missed there which is attachment to
members allowance which
um
we have
in the last five years we have had a
couple of cases where we have put
attachment on members allowances
but that as you can see as a proportion
is a very very tiny percentage
um so yes so enforcement agents um we
get between sort of
two two and a half percent of the cases
end up with an enforcement agent
but as i said the purpose of that is
really just to continue to negotiate as
payment arrangements
so cases that go to an enforcement agent
generally get paid at the rate of sort
of 50 to 55
of what gets referred to them gets
collected by an enforcement agent
and anything up to 50 get paid at that
very first stage where an enforcement
agent doesn't ever go to a property it's
done via letter
if it does get to the stage of the
customers on
engaging and it
does get to an enforcement stage
that's where the enforcement agents will
actually go to the property and talk to
the customer about the debt and try to
negotiate payment arrangement
of those that um
between 50 to 66 are paid at that stage
where that with the enforcement agent
will actually uh visit the property
the thing i think members probably most
concerned about is how many actually do
we then remove the goods for
um in the last five years we've had two
cases in five years where we've removed
goods
and we would only do that where there
were absolutely justifiable reasons for
doing that and it would only be
authorised by again a senior officer
can i just interrupt just to reinforce
that point members two
people within five years and i just
think that's something we really need to
shout about and congratulate ourselves
for
because if you look at the national
average being one percent
we've done way way better than that so
i'll let mrs green continue now but i
think that's really important we
we take that on board
from from our perspective we see that as
a success because
we are
minimizing the numbers of customers that
are being subjected to those more severe
enforcement actions so absolutely
on the very final slide what we've done
is to again give you those numbers
because we're giving you the percentages
because i think that helps show from
when we send the bills the percentage of
people that we engage with and how that
gradually produces as we go further down
the enforcement process
so to put some sort of actual numbers on
that and we've given you them there so
we've got reminders
we roughly send out seven thousand
reminders a year
um there's about
two and a half thousand final notices
somewhere around one and a half to two
thousand summonses
um which ends up with numbers of
liability orders just been just over a
thousand
um so
we we do send out the letters requesting
um additional information
about the customer's details income and
expenditure to every single person that
we take action through the courts on
um
and then they said the
the attachment of earnings and benefit
orders are in there between 100 to 250 a
year
members attachment of allowances as i
mentioned it's two over five years
um
and the rest i think a percentage is
there apart from the removal of goods
which is as i said two customers in five
years
so i hope that's been helpful members i
i hope that's giving you the reassurance
i think that you were seeking in terms
of our approach
um i'm very proud of our our team
they are very dedicated very customer
focused
and
if i say it myself they do an absolutely
fantastic job and i'm very very proud of
what they achieve
happy to take questions members
thank you very much and i just we're
very very happy i think i can speak for
all members say that we are very very
very proud of you and your team
so
and thank you i realized a lot of work
went into this and i'd really like to
thank you for that also acknowledge the
pressures that your team have been under
for the last year as well
and just members this is something we
need to be shouting about this is
something we're doing really really well
so i'd like to thank councillor morris
in his absence for bringing this item
because it's given us an opportunity
to
to shout about something that we do very
very well as a council i think so
thank you i will go to cancer schools
yes uh shouting about it fantastic work
um really well done
but could it be counterproductive to
actually
shout loudly about only two people being
prosecuted since
i mean
i'll just sometimes wonder whether that
might encourage people think oh probably
get away with this can really push it
i'm just wondering whether that's the
sort of thing that we can successfully
shout about and whether it might be
counterproductive i think the point is
that our systems are so effective that
actually people don't get to that stage
and the support we give to people
is over and above that that they would
receive from other authorities that
enables people
not to get in debt
yes uh
through chair yes sir i think those are
good messages but uh i do i'm just
alerting you to the potential danger of
how we might shout about a success like
that thank you thank you any other
members like to speak councillor mays
uh yeah thank you mr madam chair you
listen to me again i know i corrected
thank you um
thank you very much um ms green
absolutely brilliant well talked through
uh i think everything was was very clear
just one very small thing that i wanted
to ask which was regarding the
attachments of earnings um and you refer
to attachments of benefits and
attachments of members allowance
how i wasn't quite clear at what point
those come into play
and whether or not they could come into
play a bit earlier on
in the system
um so that we can actually then reduce
the numbers even further than they
already are and i'm very impressed with
the numbers that as they stand at the
moment
i believe that's governed by legislation
isn't it or is it uh it is members the
it's only when you get the liability
order that enables us to make those
deductions
there's nothing to stop a resident if
they want to approach their employer to
make those voluntary deductions but in
terms of us being able to ask the
employer to do it unfortunately he's
only at that later stage once we've
actually got a liability order
thank you yeah could i just come back on
that's a lot of teammates completely
understand the system
um so if somebody
says to
one of your staff that um
that's something that they would
welcome
can you
go down that process and help them
actually
enable that to happen or is that
something you would then pass on to
citizens advice bureau um where we
procure a lot of our
support from
thank you
so if a resident wants us to do an
attachment um order
we can do it but it is only at those
later enforcement stages we can't do it
ahead of the liability order being
granted by the court so if somebody was
struggling and perhaps needed some help
with budgeting absolutely that's where
we would involve the citizens advice
brilliant thank you very much thank you
anyone else um counselor stan
thank you no questions but just like to
say oh sorry i'm going to give way
because there's councillors
passenger and beale now everyone's
jumping in now so i will go to you
council passenger then council beale
thank you very
thank you very much councillor stamp
just just one
sort of thing really um
so the way it kind of looks to me is
that
if there is a vulnerable person
that we do everything possible we can
before we send in the agency the
enforcement agency
is that sort of
that's absolutely correct
so at what point did the enforcement
agency then
spot a vulnerable person if we already
haven't done that
it's generally where the resident hasn't
engaged with us at all so where they've
had the letters they've had the notices
we might have tried to phone them
and they've ignored all of that and
sometimes an enforcement agent turning
up on the door is the first time we
actually get to understand that that
person
might have mental health problems or um
might be unwell might be elderly and and
quite often that's what happens is that
it's that face to face when they they
actually see somebody for the first time
because unfortunately if people are in
debt
one of the things we find is people just
ignore it and hope it will go away
just just to come back i mean i'm not
trying to knock you know knock the
system but it just seems to me that if i
mean
enforcement agencies are not really the
most touchy feely
people in the world and i think
when it gets to the point where the
enforcement agency actually go there for
instance i mean how do they get paid are
they paid on commission or
are we paying them how does that work
the legislation sets out a fee that is
charged to the resident so there's a set
amount that the the enforcement agents
can collect as part of the debt
so it isn't an open-ended there is a set
amount that they are able to charge
so again
so no collection no pay basically
that's correct so it just seems
i mean it just seems that our duty of
care really should really make sure that
we spot the vulnerable person before
the enforcement agent goes in because
my way of thinking cynical as it is i
know that if an agency sends in people
to vulnerable people to collect debt
they're very unlikely to be looking to
be picking up whether or not they're
vulnerable or not they're more
interested in picking up their debt i
would have thought
i can just interject there i mean i
think how you uh spot someone that
completely refuses to engage i really
don't understand council messenger but
i'm reassured by the fact that the um
enforcement agents do have a vulnerable
person
referral system
themselves i mean they're clearly used
to dealing with vulnerable people
because that's
that's what they do and i know there
isn't very negative stereotypes around
enforcement agents but i think we
i don't think we particularly want to go
down the road of negative stereotypes
really no it's not ideal but
i don't see how our system can be any
more robust than it is
i don't know if you'd like to come back
again it's i'm trying to say i mean i i
totally agree with you but i mean we're
looking at this from sort of you know in
a perfect world but it all works
perfectly and i just think there is a
huge gap and i mean the figures justify
there isn't that many people thank
goodness but it does worry me rather
that you know
we're leaving it to the enforcement
agency at the last post to actually
decide whether or not somebody is
vulnerable or not when actually there's
money involved we're not council
messenger i think is the answer to that
we're not only in the extra most extreme
circumstances where
a person has absolutely refused to
engage with us
that's the only point i think mrs green
if we've had absolutely no engagement
from a resident
would would we would they not be picked
up as vulnerable am i right
that's absolutely right so we would use
multiple forms as well so we would look
at if we've got a telephone number an
email
by post we would do every form of
communication we could to try and ensure
that we we do pick up anybody that we
think is vulnerable
we also work very closely with our
colleagues for example in the housing
team
because
that person may well be claiming
benefits might well have housing issues
so again where appropriate we will try
to identify vulnerability from any other
records that we have as well
so
is do we have an officer or something
sort of an in-between person before the
agency actually go in so i know we're
sort of sending letters and phone calls
and you know
i just i just think you know when people
are very vulnerable it's you know they
they they fall through you know they go
through the net and sometimes
you know
i mean it's you know i don't understand
what you're doing but i just wondered if
we had an officer or
somebody that goes and actually knocks
on the door before we send in the heavy
heavy brigade and
tries to establish what's going on
we don't um and
if i'm honest i'm not sure that sending
somebody from the council
to them
um in a lot of cases would make a lot of
difference because they're not engaging
with us anyway
and and the number of people that are
vulnerable are relatively small as well
so i think you know it's not all of the
people the enforcement agency with it is
a minority but absolutely it's important
that you know we protect that minority
so we do absolutely everything that we
can and as i said if it gets to the
stage of an enforcement agent knocking
on the door and they identify that there
is someone that's vulnerable they walk
away
they don't deal with it anymore they
pass it to a separate team they're
completely independent they they're not
part of the actual um team that go out
and and collect debts they're totally
independent and they would always refer
back to us in terms of we've been to
this property we've come across somebody
who we think might have some mental
health issues we think they probably
need some extra support what do you want
us to do
and we will quite often say either
suspend action or send the case back to
us we'll get the citizen's advice
involved we will make that contact
so that so it's absolutely looking at
every opportunity as soon as there's a
[ __ ] there that we have concerned
absolutely enforcement action suspended
um and we will give that opportunity to
make sure we understand that's the
situation before we take any further
action
thank you
thank you um councilman i believe
oh yeah thank you um
can you oh i'm sorry uh actually
councillor b also counseled
just about three points what about um
debts that are created within another
district
how do we cover that situation
for collection when they're in our
district also what happens when a person
dies of natural causes and also
um
who is the officer at mall district
council or what committee is it that
will
resolve the matter by
eliminating that debt
something to test you mrs green
right so the local authority where the
debt was incurred will be responsible
for collecting that debt so there's
never a suggestion that the debts will
be passed on to another local authority
so
if somebody lived in colchester and old
cultures to 500 pounds they came here
and odas 1500
they would still have to pay that
original 500 back to colchester and it
would be up to cultures to take action
in respect of that debt
so just that
is that okay for the first one
and the second one if somebody does die
um it kind of depends on whether or not
they leave any estate
so we would send an account would be
sent to the executives of the estate
when that person has died
and we would register our interest and
it would depend on whether there was any
money in the estate as to whether or not
the debt was paid
if there wasn't any money in the estate
then we can
write that debt off and and that's
exactly what we do do if there is no no
possible ability to recover the debt
it depends on the amount of the debt if
it's a relatively small amount then
officers have got delegated powers to
write those debts off
the larger debts have to be signed off
by a senior officer and a lot of the
really large debts which i believe is
over 10 000 come back to members and
they have to be written off through the
strategy and resources committee
could i come back and ask a further
question please what happens if a person
absconds and goes abroad
and so you can't collect the money in
this country do we hold that debt open
until a person returns or do we write it
off
we try to avoid ever writing debts off
because there will be times when people
might have they might have scones but
sometimes they they come back
so absolutely we would not necessarily
write a debt off and we would use every
power that we have to be able to trace
them so we do have access to certain
government systems
we share information with other local
authorities so we have lots of data
matching with other authorities
and there's some national data matching
as well so again we use every power that
we can to identify um where we have got
people that have got debts
um
and we would absolutely do everything we
can to recover those
thank you very much
thank you thank you very much ah
councillor nice natalie yeah thank you
um yeah mr green um could you give me
some idea as to what sort of training
and support that you give our staff
on identifying uh vulnerable
residents
that may find themselves in debt
and is that ongoing training
thank you it absolutely is so all of the
staff that come to us ideally comes with
some um previous experience of dealing
with debts if they don't then we
absolutely will give them a lot of
training a lot of it is
with our other experienced officers so
we'll be working alongside them
and they will only be given
very small remits to do things so to
start with they might be able to
negotiate payment arrangements and once
they are become more experienced we'll
let them then undertake other forms of
enforcement so
never ever will we put somebody who is
not fully experienced to be able to do
the full gambit of recovery action
and again we're very proud of the way
that we support our staff and the
training that we give them and we have
got a number of our staff across the
revenue benefits service that are
professionally trained with our double
rv qualifications which you've supported
for them to do
could could i come back and ask one more
question you could then cancel humor
then council of bassinger thank you um
you said that we're adept sorry you said
you said that we're a collection agency
uh which which we are we collect uh some
big big figure i seem to remember i
wrote down somewhere
several million um if we don't collect
that money let's say we only collect 30
million instead of 40 million
um are we still paying out the
percentage that we need to to all the
other agencies and we then have to
retain that debt going forward
absolutely whether however well we do
with our collection rates
we are ultimately the ones that will be
financially affected so
we only benefit from
around about 12 13 of the overall amount
that we collect but whether we collect
the debt or not we still have to pay
essex county council there
70 or however much it is so yes
absolutely we fully meet the cost of any
non-collection
thank you madam chairman thank you
councillor who knows that counselor
messenger am i pronouncing you right yes
you are yes thank you
yes my question has just been answered
there where um if we you know we don't
get the money in
what percentage of that is then
collected and how do we do it yes
that's right so yes so so you're
good with good with that thank you
council messenger
sorry just to go back to the thing of
vulnerability
it seems to me i mean you've explained
it all very well and and i take all of
that on board but it just seems as
though you know there's like
an agency knocks on the door and they
are you know surprised there is a
vulnerable person where we've had a huge
surely a huge history with this person
we've tried to engage with them we've
sent them letters so how is it that we
haven't already spotted that they are
vulnerable
as i mentioned earlier it's generally
where that customer has not engaged in
any way shape or form with us so we've
got no idea that they are vulnerable and
that's the issue i think the cases that
we have had where we've identified
vulnerability at a later stage is
absolutely 100 where that customer has
not engaged with us and we've had no way
of knowing that they are vulnerable
and as i mentioned earlier we will use
all the means at our disposal to try and
identify if we do have a vulnerable
person and even if there's a suspicion
that person is vulnerable
but if we have absolutely no no idea
that they are
unfortunately there are occasions when
it is later down the line we just
discover they're vulnerable but if that
happens as i say our our position is
that we don't proceed on that basis that
as soon as we know they're vulnerable
then we absolutely take a different
approach
okay thank you thank you
yes on the question of vulnerability uh
do you um
i know i'm taking cancer bachelor's
point that perhaps the best person to
spoil vulnerability is no it might not
be a bailiff
i understand of course there'll be cost
implications of employing someone to do
a pre-check on on people who aren't
responding to see if they're
vulnerable or not if they're not
responding is there an agency that you
can speak to a voluntary agency some
people who provide care in the community
who could check for you is there a means
by which we can
just
try
since you say that selling a council
officer round would wouldn't work is
there a sort of somewhere sort of
a cost effective halfway house between
um complete silence and the bale of
turning up at the door is that something
that is possible or considered or done
are we governed by legislation here
no members if members felt that that was
something that an additional step that
they would like to be put into the
process absolutely it's something we
could do
um
that would be um
the numbers of cases that go that go to
an enforcement agent that would be a
fairly big undertaking but certainly if
you wanted us to look at that it's
certainly something we could do the only
thing i would say is that
the numbers of people that are
identified as vulnerable are very very
small compared with the overall numbers
so proportionally the resource that
would go into identifying a relatively
small number of vulnerable people
um is something that you know would need
to be carefully considered but
absolutely it's something that we could
do
thank you now as some
just gonna check i believe mr screen
that um
one suggestion you had was that that
member that they because i believe the
corporate debt strategy is being
reviewed at the moment and i believe
that one of your suggestions was that
mem that would come to members
so i'm just thinking maybe this is
something that could be discussed
in that process if we make that
recommendation absolutely so the
corporate debt strategy is three
nearly four years old
so we have got some updates to due to it
in terms of some of the changes that
have happened with the legislation so
we're planning to bring that back to
members
next year in terms of an update so what
we members could do is any
recommendations that came out of this
scrutiny review
could be fed in as part of that
reconsideration of the corporate debt
strategy and that's absolutely and the
suggestion from councillor bassinger of
putting in that extra step is something
that members may want to consider
councilman's then council passenger uh
yeah thank you um madam chair um i also
think that um
we need to make the process much more
visible online
and i think this is also going to be
looked at um
it will be yeah the website is
definitely somewhere you know if
somebody decides that they want to
tackle their debt
they ask mr google and they want an
answer
you know they they don't want to have to
be searching around too much
for for the information that they need
and i do think that that is quite an
important recommendation going going
forward thank you thank you council
passenger i believe you wanted to come
here i was just wondering again if is
there any way that people i mean
i mean i presume we sort of keep records
of people that are elderly or disabled
and all these things we have all this
stuff
but is there any way that um people
could actually register themselves as as
being or feeling that they're vulnerable
whether it's financially it could be one
parent families where they could
actually put themselves if they wanted
to on that register to be considered by
council
so as for instance
just going forward so if they felt
themselves coming into difficulty or
falling on hard times or whatever their
vulnerability is
they could actually register themselves
so as we do have a record of people who
are willing to be recognized as
vulnerable is that
i would suggest that's a very dangerous
stupid thing to say
i think if the customer has come forward
to recognize they have a vulnerability
we would be picking that up anyway now
because they've made that contact the
problem is that people aren't making
that contact with us
and also vulnerability is sometimes a
perception sometimes it's a temporary
thing sometimes it's longer term so
i think it is quite difficult but
absolutely if somebody
said anything to us that gave us
concerns that they were vulnerable we
would
take that step at that point of treating
them as potentially vulnerable and
putting the extra controls in place
and also that person would be engaging
if they were registering themselves then
they would be engaging with the council
and therefore they wouldn't fit into the
um
the sub group of people that are getting
the first contact from the bailiffs
cancer stand yeah thank you i mean i'm
really interested in the figures i mean
it's great what council passengers
suggesting and i'm all for if we can
actually
support anybody who is vulnerable but we
also need to know the figures because
normally within our society in our
communities somebody is aware of
somebody who may be vulnerable or the
cvs is there's often some services you
know that you could raise the query with
yourself and as long as there's a
confidential avenue i've done it myself
where i've gone in somewhere and i've
thought oh my goodness me and and then
you would contact somebody and nine
times out of ten you could be incorrect
madam chair um but i totally agree and
if we can look at it and it can be
adapted and but i'd like to know the
figures that the numbers of people are
actually talking about and really two
one is is is too many two is definitely
too many because they are the most
vulnerable but we've also got to be
realistic and if that can be brought in
with confidentiality etc i think we
should do it but can i just say madam
chair that i know that these two items
that have been brought to this committee
tonight
were delayed or deferred from a previous
meeting but i'd like to say that the
officers who presented tonight it was
well worth the wait because i would
think a lot of us didn't know that
and i know you said how much hard work
and i know the other members have as
well i didn't know half of what was been
explained to us today and that's not
just because we're new newly elected
members it's because we're actually
going to the responsibilities of the
offices so i'd like to thank you on
behalf of everybody in this council for
both of you and your team behind you has
done this information because a lot of
hard work's gone into that i said that's
a lot of years information um ms green
so um thank you but i totally agree with
councillor bassinger and if there is
anything um we could we can do then i
think it should come back to the either
this committee or the council in future
thank you thank you council staff i do
just want to clarify that there's no
suggestion that those two people that
that had goods removed were vulnerable
no i'm well aware of that i didn't infer
they were did i but you didn't okay
just to clarify in case members
listening well i can't always interpret
how people interpret what i say
counselor bell and i think you will
agree with that if we could councilors
don't we'd probably be earning millions
of pounds somewhere else rather than
being here
okay members well i would like to um
i would like to propose
that
we do look at
when this comes back that we do
investigate the potential for an
additional step
just to
ensure
that we are doing everything we can
um i would like to propose that
the website is updated to make it much
much easier to find information about
that debt i mean i'll be looking at just
a button on the home page that you hit
and it takes you to
my understanding is that currently you
have to look at corporate debt policies
of ideal strategy to find the
information
so my recommendation is those two
originally i was going to request that a
working group report back to pg a but
i'm not sure because of the low numbers
i'm not sure we actually need that but
i'm happy to
adopt that if members think council maze
i think you wanted to speak uh yeah i
was just going to come back on the the
website thing it needs to be a really
plain english you know please please
avoid any jargon
um make it easy for for everybody
young and old alike to understand thank
you
thank you
so i mean do we think we need a working
group to report to pgna what do we think
about that members
no
in which case i'm proposing that with
those two
provisos that we look at the website
update the website
and we investigate the feasibility of an
additional step as part of the review of
the corporate debt strategy that we then
close this item members do i have a
second
council
cancer schemes members can we agree that
by sense
thank you and thanks again just to echo
what council stamps said thank you very
very much for that it was extremely
helpful and illuminating so
thank you
okay
agenda item 10 any other items of
business that the chairman decides are
urgent you will be very relieved to know
memphis that there are none so
thank you very much everybody for your
contributions this evening and i now
draw the meeting to a close at
9 25 pm
thank you very much
and the meeting is now closed members
are advised not to enter into any
further discussion